maurepas et monte son se sont retrouvés
ce dimanche 24 février en match en
retard du championnat de d1 de district
à domicile les morts pas un prennent
rapidement le jeu à leur compte arrive à
conclure dans le premier quart d'heure
grâce à yakubu belfodil montesson réagi
tir une minute plus tard sur la barra et
ce sont finalement les verts qui arrive
à faire le break grâce à leur numéro 9
le joueur est proche d'inscrire un
triplé quelques minutes plus tard mais
échoue 2 à 0 à la mi temps on a la
chance de marquer très tôt dans le match
voilà on n'est pas rentré dans le match
on est on est concentrés on a le ballon
on joue bien
donc on est content malgré que on
pouvait mettre encore de plus je pense
plus voilà c'est bonne première mi-temps
dans l'ensemble mais il faut faire mieux
en deuxième période pour vraiment plier
le match et les mettre le moral à zéro
l'équipe adverse
au retour des vestiaires mort pas se
voir refuser deux buts dont un pur enjeu
montesson pousse ensuite pour revenir
dans le match et s'offrent une grosse
occasion en milieu de seconde période
mais ce sont finalement les mots repas
indien qui arrivent à se mettre à l'abri
avec un troisième but inscrit par
l'inarrêtable et jakub belfodil sur ce
lob montesson tentera de réduire le
score mais la défense des verts tient
bon score final 3 à 0
votre but en temps surtout pour la
victoire aussi a fait ça fait du bien de
renouer avec la victoire à domicile
devant nos supporters donc on est
content on est content d forcément aussi
et tout le monde était concentré dans
les duels on a mis le bois l'impact
qu'ont été ont été solides on est bien
ressortir proprement toujours de prendre
0 buts dans un match joueurs ça fait
toujours plaisir
être fort dans la tête aussi maintenant
on peut faire mieux encore on fait
quelconque offre quelques petites
boulettes encore quelques soucis à
régler quoi avec cette victoire morpain
remonte à la 5e place du classement et
s'éloigne de la zone de relégation
prochain match le 10 mars sur le terrain
de gargenville